[Music]
on today's show we talk teen pregnancy
we talk postpartum depression
and we talk to a woman who just got an
awesome job promotion
but she's terrified of the public
speaking that comes with it stay tuned
hey what's up good folks i'm john and
this is the dr john deloney show
pull up a seat at the bar and grab
something to eat everybody's welcome
in a world gone mad where we define
ourselves by who we hate this show is
for those who are sick of fighting
and yelling and hating improving
and who just want to show up and do the
next right thing
who just want to start hanging out with
people again and not
yelling at everybody again so this show
is about your mental health about your
relationships
about everything right family parenting
relational iq
questions schooling anything you can
come up with addiction
we cover it all here give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one
or go to johndaloni.com fill out the
form it could go to kelly she's probably
not gonna read it but she might just
kidding she reads them all
and man her psychosis her mental health
is just
it's on a free fall tom petty wrote
about it many many moons ago hey and
while we have the uh
the the background camera up you can see
james is now texting me saying hey bro
let's wear the same clothes
he said today was a blue plaid checker
day and i said
yes sir and i didn't wear a hat today
you didn't even wear a hat last week
you said hey um curl your hair like mine
and i tried i couldn't make it work i
got stuck in the flat iron but whatever
all right so let's go straight to the
phones today let's go to brianna in
lakeland florida
brianna what's going on how can i help
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
thank you for calling um
yeah um so i guess the gist of it
uh i am where my husband and i are
expecting our
second kid in april um
so if i sound a little winded it's
because i'm very pregnant
um just went right good yeah
yeah but um so april that's just a
minute like that's coming by the time
this show comes out
your your little one may be here right
yeah exactly yeah so
uh we're very excited um my husband
works a job
that requires him to deploy two months
at a time and then he's home for two
months
um and during our our first son
he was he because of the coveted
lockdowns he actually ended up being
gone for
five months when our young our first son
was about
three months old so uh all that to say
i really struggled during that time with
um
postpartum depression and uh just the
sleep deprivation
and i know you really talk about how
important sleep is but i was just kind
of wondering
how do we handle communicating from a
distance
and working through that lack of sleep
because you know you can only get
so much with the newborn for real had
any advice with
with dealing with the emotions that just
come from that
so walk us through um
what it what it was like we for those
people who experience postpartum
depression
right they have a feeling a sense i've
walked into some
some homes and sat with folks and it is
like very
few things i've ever seen but for those
who think they know
what it is that it's just they're people
are just a little bit
bummed or a little bit more weepy walk
the average listener who's just
you know mowing their yard right now or
driving to work who
really doesn't have insight walk them
through what that was like
um yeah so so for me especially
not having my husband around i'm just
kind of being me and the baby and we had
my parents and some other help but um it
was
which sometimes is good and sometimes
that makes sense right
you're performing too and you haven't
showered or slept in four weeks and
you're
still trying to to do the song and dance
for mom and dad but go ahead
oh yeah but um for me
it was just a lot of pressure
and it got to the point where i felt
like not only did i feel like i wasn't
doing a good job but it felt like
um i i just didn't even like my child
sometimes
uh which i'm sure you know we all go
through those phases but
it just you know even to my husband i'd
say like wow why did we do this so
well we were ready for this i it just
was like drowning it was overwhelming
um and it was especially bad like i'm
just
i like my sleep as most people do um
so getting up every two hours or you
know being up till one because he just
won't fall asleep for any reason
just got to the point where i was like i
i don't even
i don't even like you and then you feel
guilty for that then you get to get
in that way loop and then your head
starts spinning i'm the worst mom
ever and then that turns into i just
want to hug him and then he won't stop
screaming and then now we're back on
that
that loop right when did you know i need
to go reach out to somebody
um i
got so like i said it was all kind of
during the covered lockdowns my husband
got stuck
deployed for five months when it was
only supposed to be two
and that was a lot tougher and it got to
the point where one day i was
driving back from the grocery store
and the baby was just unbelievably upset
and wouldn't stop crying and i just
instantaneously like thought flash
through my head of
i i could just drive this car right off
the road yep
and it would just in and out like that i
didn't dwell on it and you know you say
a lot about like we can control our
thoughts
um but just even the fact that that
crossed my mind i was like oh
that's that's not good that's not a good
one
yeah i'm gonna file that one into the
probably not
right yes yeah good for you hey listen
that's so brave because that's a scary
thought
that pops in a lot of folks heads right
and then most most people will bury that
one so good for you
you knew ah that one probably crossed
even my own lines right
yeah ah i'm so proud of you okay
so when was this this your your youngest
or your
only to this point when were they born
when was he born uh he was born in june
of 2019.
okay and so was about
how long about a a year or i guess six
seven months when your husband took off
that sounded awful like your husband
took off when your husband was deployed
right
for the longest stretch of deployment he
he's done a couple trips now since then
but um
for the the longest and the hardest he
was probably in that
six to 12 month range and do you have
anybody like so let's take family aside
some family is real real helpful some
family is
real real not helpful and so
let's take your family out do you have a
group one or two or three
women in your life who've already had
kids that you can text and say
is this normal or were you on your own
um i have some friends but they're
mostly like we had
moved to florida to be near my parents
and most of our friends with kids were
on california
and with lockdowns not being able to go
to a church or meet any new women
um i i had some i would say i probably
could have reached out to but
i think a lot of it was just me being
too afraid to
i guess trust that with anyone other
than my husband
yes and that was a lot of pressure on
him because he couldn't do anything he
was
out of the country and that he felt
helpless
which then you feel like i need to
protect him from this
and so then it just gets quieter and
quieter and quieter right yeah
and so as you've as you've spoken it out
i hope you've heard the arc here
right so all postpartum is such a unique
experience and there are people who
are this is all they do is work with
postpartum depression and there are
some extraordinary ob gyns
who have really dug into not only
women's health but also
postpartum psychiatric help and i've got
several friends several folks i've
worked with who have talked to me about
how awful it is if someone doesn't know
what they're doing
or how incredible it is when someone
sits down and just listens to you right
and so i want to say up front i'm not a
postpartum expert
and more importantly i've never
experienced this
and um so me trying to tell you who's
experienced it what you should do just
sounds kind of ridiculous right but i'm
gonna give it a shot okay so i want
everyone listening to know
i know the last thing on earth is some
dude
giving uh somebody else uh postpartum uh
advice right but as i listen to you tell
this narrative
here's a couple things i picked out
number one
your bedrock got stuck somewhere else
this guy that you lean on right was
stuck somewhere else
at a time when they just closed the
board like
it was scary for everybody right and
there's no
there's no chance he's coming home
because my guess is he was gone for two
months and then he said hey baby i'm
probably gonna be gone for a couple of
weeks
which turned into a month which is like
hey i think they're gonna let us go hold
on no it's gonna be
right so that thing kept moving and
moving right and that gets
scarier and scarier especially as baby
gets louder and louder
and you get more isolated more alone and
then you
had just moved and man the thing i
beyond sleep is this this this
disease that we've got in the disease's
loneliness
right and you found yourself with nobody
you couldn't reach out to anybody and
you're too good of a friend to wake
people up on california time
and it got more lonely and your internal
alarms ring
louder and louder and louder and then
you talked about that loop
and the most common the most common
phrase i hear from women who's
struggling from postpartum
is i can't believe my kid got stuck with
me as their mom
right in that devastating feeling that
somehow you're going to ruin this kid
you don't like them you don't want them
and of course you love them but in those
at 2 a.m i don't like anybody at 2am
right
and so it all starts to loop on itself
so
here's here's my number one thing i
would tell you is
to partner with your doctor in this
journey and let them know hopefully
you've already done that have you
already done that let them know hey last
time this was tough
um i haven't i haven't brought it up
okay um
yeah i want you so so shame
and this depression it eats one thing
from for a meal and that is secrets okay
and i want you to know i don't care what
thoughts went in your head and i've
heard some
really aggressive i've heard some
violent thoughts i've heard some
really tough stuff you're not
nuts okay i want you to be open with
your doctor especially they're not going
to take your kid away
i want you to be open with obviously
your husband
but i want you to rally a team okay
so that can look like your parents
his parents that can look like any new
friends
that can look like friends from
california but i want you to have a team
and you
are the ceo you're the quarterback you
were the the military commander
and i want you to be really vocal and
direct about what you need
okay here's what that's going to look
like i'm going to i want to tap
you two or you three you three friends
from california that you're really close
to
i want you to let them know i need you
guys during this season i'm going gonna
text you at crazy
hours i'm gonna text you crazy things
i'm gonna call you
weeping like mad and i'm trusting you
to help me get from here to there okay
so i want you to
and i want they're gonna feel so honored
that you are bringing them into this and
tell them they are your a team
right and then if there is a college kid
if there is a church friend even if it's
your parents
or your in-laws let them know i'm gonna
call
at two o'clock in the morning and i want
you all to show up
if it's a college camera to pay you
right or maybe there's some nights of
the week you bring them over for
uh to spend the night with you and let
them know if the baby wakes up there's
where the bottles are i'm gonna pay you
50 bucks for being here overnight or
whatever that is and
but i gotta get some sleep and i want
you to protect that
but more importantly i want you to
practice leaning on other people
i also think that this go around is
gonna be different because you know some
of the body things
some of the thought things and you will
have some sort of understanding of
oh we're headed in a rough direction
right
and then you know these things right
about healthy food and sleep and outside
walking exercising those things
and that's why i want you to be upfront
about calling people
and so when your mother-in-law comes
over she's gonna know we're not talking
or hanging out we are not friends i am
going for a walk and then i'm taking a
three-hour nap right
but if you are up front that upfront in
this
if you will it's not even a word can be
a real gift to people around you who
want to help but they don't know what to
do
so they come over and they feel like
they have to entertain you and then they
talk
talk talk talk talk right and then
here's the last
final thing do not become
hyper aware or manic about
looking for all of any of these low
moments or any thoughts or anything like
that does that make sense
because what you're gonna do when you
have this baby you're gonna be like okay
when's the next bad thought coming
when's it coming when's it cut right and
you can almost
will it to existence right or
tonight's gonna be the night i don't
sleep and then man then the rest for
sure you're not gonna sleep now
so deal with it when they come but don't
put it out into the universe
just be ready to love this knucklehead
is it boy or girl
uh it's a boy okay so you're gonna have
two boys yep
oh that's so fun all right so just be
ready to love this knucklehead with all
of your heart and know that your other
baby is going to be bananas too oh it's
all going to be a
mayhem and a mess yeah and you've got to
have a team next to you and
and i started this with make sure your
doctor knows
i'm going to end this with don't hide
things from your doctor
okay let them know hey i had this
thought i had that thought i had
these dark feelings i thought about just
taking a quick sharp left turn into
oncoming traffic i'm so tired
i just want this to stop and they will
look at you and they will say i hear you
you're okay and then they will give you
some help
moving forward right they're not going
to steal your baby from you they're not
going to take from they hear this stuff
with some regularity because postpartum
is a hard
hard demon okay so if somebody else
reaches out to you
and they say hey i'm about to have a
baby will you be on my a team i want you
to say
yes yes what a gift that can be to other
folks
my wife had that it was a lifeline
an absolute lifeline especially when one
of them said
at one point one of the pregnancies hey
probably should go talk to somebody
right this is getting heavy and it was
somebody that my wife trusted and it was
good
so hey listen brianna you are awesome
you're a great great mom you are not
bananas
i don't say you're normal but you're
normal you love your kid you're gonna
love the second one
and it's gonna be messy and hard so what
can you do right now you can move
all these hard decisions up front before
they get bananas get an
a team get a backup team get a slate of
babysitters if you can
if you can you're a pregnant mom you can
do whatever you want right or your
husband's gonna be wandering around the
house wondering what he can do to help
tell put him on babysitter duty and it
may just be having somebody come over
and spend the night so you can
sleep the entire night right protect
that sleep protect your health protect
your
your um getting outside right
protect your knowledge and don't
be afraid to reach out thank you so so
much for that call brianna if you if
somebody's listening to this or um
watching
listening to watching this on the
internet and you've got some some tips
for folks who experienced by
postpartum you've experienced it and you
were able to to come up with some good
strategies you were a coach to it
leave those comments in the comment
section here
don't leave anything stupid and mean
leave positive things that are going to
help people
when they're struggling with postpartum
people are going to google i'm
struggling with postpartum how do i help
they're going to come to this video so
leave some great things down below
don't leave any nonsense or idiocracy
and brianna after your baby's born
write in let us know everything's
healthy everybody who's doing great
and we'll be rooting for you all right
let's go to frank in ottawa canada
what's up my frank how are we doing
uh hi there dr john i'm well how are you
i'm good i'm good
so what's going on man well um
well thank you for taking my call i
really appreciate your advice and wisdom
so i'm hoping you can shed some light
for me and my wife on this situation so
what's happening is
our 19 year old daughter is pregnant
with her second child
my wife and i have legal custody or
guardianship of her first child
who's now three this pregnancy was also
unplanned
and so we are um struggling to find ways
to support her um and to
and to guide her because she's you know
not really been taking advice and so on
so
that's where we're at so when you talk
about um
number one i'm i'm glad you're there for
that little baby that's awesome
i know that wasn't how y'all drew that
up and y'all
had a whole different plan for this
season of life and um
it's awesome that y'all stepped up to
take care of that grandbaby
um when you say help and support what do
you mean
what are you thinking of when you wake
what picture do you have on how i can
support my daughter
when she won't listen to us right so
good question so the
so with the first baby um she was living
at home at the time
um and when the baby was about i don't
know
six eight months old um
she she confided in us that she was
having a really hard
time um you know being a mom which is
totally understandable it's hard being a
mom for anyone as per your first caller
you know you
just caught her and um and let alone
you know a 16 year old single mom at the
time so
anyway so we we um with the guidance of
our family therapist at the time
we came up with a family plan whereby we
would take care of the baby
and our daughter would have a chance to
go back to school and get back on our
feet and all that stuff
so that was the support we provided at
that time
now since then yeah how did you end up
with custody that that's that means the
plan didn't work like y'all thought it
was going to huh
right so so exactly so
what happened was um she ended up moving
out of the house
um got into drugs and so on and so we
actually went to court
she moved out of the house without the
baby i should say she left the baby at
home with us okay
so we went to court and uh got a court
order
for custody custody to be granted to us
so
now is there any contingency on that or
that baby's yours
um it's a temporary order for the next
uh
i want to say three three or four years
okay um
so if we work on any sort of services to
get to regain custody or does it expire
um if the what the court order says is
that they will revisit the decision
at the ex the expiry of this first order
so she's got a chance to get her crap
together and if she doesn't
then they'll revisit it and then they'll
stamp it for you okay gotcha all right
thanks so now there's another one on the
way
correct with uh with a different young
man who is
um i would say equally as poor
performing as the first one
poor person you're the most you're the
most uh
articulate father i would have said the
dude sucks but
good for you you're a better person than
me i said all the words off air so
uh you don't want your grandkid to hear
about his dad you're a good man okay
so and i and and i know that i don't i
don't want to trash
the biological father of i love our
granddaughter in front of her right
i know better than to do that but this
this young man is
is is not much better to get it so
you want to keep this baby yeah so she
is
she's definitely uh keeping the baby
she's due in august
um i think the due date is august 8th or
something like that but she's not living
at home
and what makes this situation kind of
funny or not funny but
um messy messy yeah is that she was
living
uh with him at his parents house
um but he had some sort of a nervous
breakdown a couple of weeks ago
he was hospitalized for a few days and
then prescribed
antidepressants and anti-anxiety meds
at which time his mother kicked our
daughter out of the house so she's now
living in a shelter
and us to you know
take any of the help that us family are
trying to offer
why won't she why would she rather be
pregnant living in a shelter than come
back and live at home
yeah that's a great question and you
know
um we think she she's never been
diagnosed but we think she has
oppositional defiance disorder yeah hold
on i don't care about any disorders
why won't she why won't she
love you we don't allow her enough
freedom because she wants
the freedom to come and go as she
chooses and please us to do
okay um she she like i said she was
involved in
doing drugs and drinking and stuff and
and all that stuff and
every time we tried to you know impose a
punishment or something
um it was nice as though we were
cramping her style
on so well you were rightfully so so is
she using drugs now
no she's clean now she's she's she's you
know
when she was telling my wife mom her mom
that
um she was pregnant you know she she was
telling her that she quit smoking and
she quit smoking weed and
and all the other stuff she was doing so
so she is living
in a shelter right now when's the baby
august uh august 8th i believe okay
so
[Music]
what do you what do you want to do
well you know she's 19 now you know
so there's very little we can do now
what do you want to do if you could snap
your fingers what would you have
i would have her move back in either
with us or with her grandparents who've
also been very supportive
um i would want her to
take advantage of the support that we're
lending her at least until this baby
comes and
until she can find a job and get some
money in the bank and you know
develop some sort of a foundation to
live on her own
i don't have much faith that her
boyfriend is going to be
able to take care of them you know he
probably won't but
when's the last time you and her just
got together
and wouldn't had lunch somewhere i
wouldn't ate too much pancakes
yeah it's been it's been a while would
she do that if you called her up
tomorrow and said hey let's go to
breakfast tomorrow
i'm paying uh would you come i think so
she might
yeah so do me this favor
don't do me a favor my life won't change
do yourself this favor
okay um spend a couple of days
really focusing on what
what you are willing to offer and what
your boundaries look like
and what you would love to see happen
and what is this within your power to
make happen
and then write it down
show it to your wife you all to do this
together make sure everybody's on the
same page
and then i want you in a low-key way no
drama no fanfare no
this is my last stand i want you to
invite your daughter breakfast
and i want you just to check in on her
see how she's doing
how's the pregnancy going and if your
wife's the right person for this that's
great too
she can have that meet that conversation
how's your body feeling i remember this
and that i remember when mom
i mean when my wife experienced xyz like
a human interaction
and then let her know i want you to know
we'd love to have you come home and
we've had our challenges in the past
you're 19 you're grown up now
we care about you and your health and
this baby's health
this is now going to be the brother or
sister of the other child
and we want you to know that you're
welcome home
that won't be the conversation for
fights it won't be the conversation for
and if in my house you're not gonna be
that's not that this isn't that
conversation
this conversation is you being the dad
you being the grown-up
saying i miss my baby and i want you to
be safe
and okay over the next six months and if
boyfriend gets his gets well gets his
crap together gets on the right
road and a good trajectory awesome
but i want you to know that we came
after you because you're a daughter
you're still my baby girl i need no
you're 19 and you're about to be a
mother of two
but i want you know you can come home
the time for
there's no drugs in my house the time
for you have a curfew all those times
those conversations those boundary
conversations they have to happen
they don't have to happen now
and what you want to do is re-establish
trust in connection with your with your
baby girl okay
will that work am i pollyanna probably
but here's what i want
there's gonna either she's gonna say
she's gonna
drop her shoulders and say thank you so
much or i'll think
about it regardless of what happens
she's either going to come home
or she's going to wait three or four or
five more months
she's going to be real stubborn about
this she's going to find somebody else
to move in with she's going to find some
situation
and here's what i want her to have i
wanted to have
experiences letters first person
breakfast accounts whatever that my dad
kept coming for me he kept coming for me
and he kept coming for me because
there's gonna
come a moment when she's gonna hit rock
bottom there's gonna come a moment when
she needs a warm bed
and she's gonna remember that guy love
me or she's gonna have this baby and six
months in
she's gonna be so exhausted so tired so
fill in the blank
and she's gonna remember okay that guy
loved me cause you're dealing with a
child right
she's a kid she's 19 right and so
give her a legacy of that and if she
says no say cool let's go to breakfast
again let's do breakfast every saturday
or me and mom are going to alternate
every saturday until this baby's born
just because we like you you're our
daughter
and all you're trying to do is not win
not establish boundaries not just
make sure fill in the blank you're just
trying to re-establish trust with your
daughter
she says no she says no say great i'm
gonna try again next week and this is
gonna be
real hard for you and your wife because
there's probably gonna be rejection
there's probably gonna be frustration
you're gonna see
she's gonna gain too much weight not
she's gonna lose a bunch of weight she's
not going to be healthy she's not going
to look like she's showered
it's going to be really hard and you all
have to be the super adults here and
keep going back
and going back and leaning in and
leaning in or the alternative is you can
cut her off
say best of luck to you i wish you well
oh we don't want to do that that's right
and i was going to tell you brother i
i couldn't do that to my daughter right
right now i'm going to have my
boundaries and i don't want to
i don't want you to hear me say man she
just gets to run roughshod over you guys
no
this is a prodigal son mom this is like
man come home
come home right and i also know that
when a teenager gets something in their
head
that is not accurate but that it gives
them an opportunity to pit themselves
against their family
man i'm gonna cut through all that
nonsense right i'm gonna cut through all
that crap i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be
a part of that this is the moment you
get to come home
right um when i say that how does that
sound frank
um yeah i i think
it sounds it sounds fine um you know
we've
we've definitely expressed that the you
know the porch lights on and the doors
open
uh but not in in such an intentional
manner like
like what you're like what you just
described so i think we can
we can try to continue expressing that
uh
in the way that you just described so do
you guys y'all laugh together when's the
last time you'll laugh together
uh well she was over when she actually
told us like three weeks ago she was
over
to visit with her daughter and visit
with the family
and you know we had a movie night and
popcorn and had a good time then and
that's actually when she felt
comfortable enough to tell us what was
going on
so yeah so she's a 19 year old mother of
two
she's an adult in the eyes of the law
and she's a kid
right and if this this may not work in
every family i've got a family with a
deranged sense of humor
but if this is me you know what my first
line would be
well we gave you a bunch of curfews and
rules
[Music]
that didn't work so come on all right i
mean we there's a there's an entryway to
this to be funny there's an entryway to
this to be really loving
yeah here's another beautiful thing if
you write her a letter so she can read
it when she leaves
a great thing 18 19 and 20 year olds are
are good at doing as feeling really good
in the moment
they get uncomfortable later on in the
day and the week with those
feelings like wait a minute i'm supposed
to hate my parents because they're
ruining my life
and i felt a sense of love for my dad
i gotta come up with some fill in the
blank right
if you write her a letter she can go
back to it and go back to it and go back
to it
so when she leaves the letter will have
nothing about rules those will come
the letter will have nothing about you
know you should have known better none
of that
the letter will just simply be you are
my baby girl
and i would love it if you came home i
want you to always know that we love you
your mom and i love you
we drive you crazy and you drive us
crazy
tag you're we're both hit right but you
and this new little grandbaby are gonna
have a place to go
be hyper intentional be with not at
this is a mother of two man right
there's a mother too
be with not at and i hope man i'm so
hopeful that you can come in humbly
if there's things you need to apologize
for if you raise your voice yelled acted
like an idiot
this is that moment for you to go first
be humble just say because the goal here
is reconnection they're not go
the goal here isn't to lecture right the
goal here is
safe baby and grandbaby the goal here is
not to win an argument and to
establish those boundaries those will
come this is the moment for connection
dude i love your heart frank let us know
how that conversation goes
let me know dude i'm i'm gonna be
thinking about this one
let me know how that conversation goes
with you and your daughter
how that breakfast goes and man if she
comes back
moves back in with you guys we'll cheer
you on and if she doesn't we'll cheer
you on anyway man thank you so much for
that call
all right so i want to go to an email
real quick um this is an email that we
get a bunch of
and so kelly pulled just a
representative one
here we go it says what do you do what
do you book you recommend
educate on how to have hard
conversations i've heard you
and dave ramsey mention it often i know
i struggle with this but i can't seem to
force myself to fix it
and not only for myself but my spouse
and children when i managed to bring up
the hard topic it is hard for the other
person too
and the conversation ends up going
nowhere i've been there
all right so um here's two classic books
i'm gonna pull them up here um and james
we'll link to these in the show notes
the book one is crucial conversations
tools for talking when stakes are high
by patterson greeny and
and etc and the other one is difficult
conversations by douglas stone bruce
patton
and sheila heen these are good books
right
here's a couple of thoughts i've never
these are good
i've always got good at practicing
hard conversations by being really
intentional right so here's a couple of
thoughts on hard conversations number
one
hard conversations are stories they
aren't battles they aren't blamed
they're about relational movement
and problem solving right it's why i
hate some modern media and even some
approaches to our legal system
we are obsessed with blame whose fault
who did this what happens
when this is your approach you never get
around to solving the problem because
everyone's obsessed with blaming others
and then when i get blamed i gotta
defend myself
right so generally people are in two
camps they want to win
engagements right they want to win a
hard conversation or they get crushed in
a hard conversation
they're doormats right so here's what i
want you to do
i want you to write down a list of the
hard conversations you need to have
right write them down right and who you
need to have them
with and they're going to rank they're
going to have order to them right
they're going to have like i've got to
tell my wife
about leaving the towels on the floor i
can't han i cannot step over wet towels
anymore
it's making me insane all the way down
to i need to have a really hard
conversation with my dad
about how he treated so and so on the
holidays i just made that up my old man
was great
but you know what i'm talking about i
want you to ride them all the way down
right so if you are someone who must win
at
all cost i want you to get with your
spouse or your friend someone you trust
i want you to practice presenting the
challenge and
letting them pretend to return and you
are
not allowed to return fire you can only
say
thank you thank you for sharing that
right so if you're somebody that
you know that let's say your wife comes
in and says hey you were late last night
and you are so quick
you have a your your mind is fast why
are you late last night you're always
late and your response was
oh yeah well and you fill in the blank
rule you can rapid fire you can slice
and dice somebody up right
then i want you to have look at your
list of conversations i need to have
and i want you to have them i want you
to practice one with your buddies
and all you can respond with is thank
you
and over the course of the next few days
i want you to process your feelings
because if you're somebody that's got to
win
it's got a great one it's going to stick
in your soul and it's going to just go
over and over
are you pissed off you can't come back
are you sad that they hurt you
what role are you playing in this issue
right
on the other side if you're a doormat i
want you to write out your answers
your thoughts and read them i want you
to practice responding in a dignified
and respectable way
so let's say your wife was yelling at
you and screaming
at you smashed a wine glass and you
laughed
the next morning you walk in and she
says oh now you're coming home
i want you to say hey let's set up a
time this afternoon for us to have a
conversation
let's set up a time and at that point
you'll have written and practiced these
things in
in a non-charged environment that's when
you're going to have this engagement
not with somebody who's ready to fight
not with a husband or a friend or a
co-worker or a boss who's ready to fight
right
i want you to practice responding in a
dignified and respectable way
and when you write it down you don't
have to worry about your thoughts
getting all jumbled up on you
and you can engage in the conversation
i'm actually both of these depending on
the topic
if it's something i get real heated
about i gotta win the engagement
right and if it's something that i know
i've played a role in
a little bit i can become a doormat and
there has been seasons when i've had
hard conversations and i actually said i
need to read this because
my thoughts are going to get all jumbled
up and i've read it and i've been able
to walk through it very succinctly
even yesterday yesterday i got a
disagreement with someone i care about
and i actually just stepped away i
actually just stepped away and came back
later
and said hey i had to step away there
here's what's going on in my heart in my
head right now
and let's have this hard conversation
right so
having these books are great i think
it's important to practice these things
with people that you trust is this
ridiculous
it can be if your buddies came over for
a couple of drinks and just play games
you're like hey by the way while we're
here
i'm going to practice having a hard
conversation with you that's going to
sound
they're going to look at you like how
about i'm just going to leave because
you're an idiot
right it's super super important to
practice and here's a big global thing
it's important that when you're having
hard conversations you've got to realize
that if you win
and they lose or if you lose and they
win
you both lose
if you both win then you both win always
know where you want to get when you're
having a hard conversation
always know what the goal of the outcome
is right where am i going with this do i
just want to hit somebody
just want to make sure they know how
much i hurt or do they need to know that
i'm going to be transitioning out of
this job because of x y and z
do they need to know this behavior is
not okay with me
talking to me or my kids or my wife
isn't okay with me
and this will not happen again or here
fill in the blank here right
remember to a folks approach folks with
curiosity hey why did you say that
hey every time i come home you always
greet me at the door
with this why right approach folks with
curiosity not judgment
and go from there check these books out
but that's my thoughts on on crucial
conversations on hard conversations
how to lean into them at the end of the
day you gotta just
do it you gotta do it ah
last thing man this drives me bananas
how often i've waited
years i've put up with just
nonsense because i didn't want to have a
hard conversation
and what i ended up doing was feeling a
little bit awful for a long long long
time
instead of having one hard hard season
have the hard conversations write them
down have them all right i'll quit
talking about that let's go to alicia in
new york city
lisa what's up how are you dr dylan
so good how about you i'm good i'm good
um i wanted to talk to you because i
pretty much have
a unique situation bring it on let's do
it
so i'm lucky enough that at work i got
picked for
a fast track program very cool that's
the upside
what's what's that what's the fast track
program like a leadership track or
something
yes dude way to go alicia
thank you thank you i'm so excited
and in this leadership program they
shoot us like you don't you sound
really sad no the thing is
i i believe me i'm excited you know
we're going to get to travel and there's
a lot of
good things coming for it's a huge
opportunity however
i cannot wrap my head around the public
speaking aspect
oh no are you glossophobic you don't
like speaking in public oh
it's it's happened late like in the last
few years i was never
i don't think i was ever this nervous
but it has gotten
terrible are you nervous now because
you're telling like
you are talking to well there's only
like 38 listeners we doubled in the last
week
does this make you nervous being on the
show or is that cool a little bit
okay a little bit a little bit all right
so walking me through you're on a stage
is it big crowds or little crowds or any
crowds
oh my god on a stage i think i i'd pass
out um
i think it's just i think it's
especially when it's work
i think it's because i put so much
pressure on myself that
i have to be on point at all times okay
so you know where does that come where
does that come from alicia
um probably because i was a young mom
okay so i've had to basically
do everything have you been able to do
everything
sorry oh you're good have you been able
no
no no no i'm not letting you get away
with luck
that's one of those things that single
moms do to
not be able to look in the mirror and
say hey you know what's up i'm
so dope i'm alicia from nyc
and i run this town
no i it's not luck i've worked your butt
off haven't you
yes and you're real smart aren't you
yes and you grow and raised you grew and
raised a human
and still managed to be on the
leadership track right
yes and i bet your baby loves you too
huh
yes i'm very blessed no
i mean you are but you're also a good
mom too right
yeah i do anything for them
ah that's so cool all right so you put a
lot into this
and you're the higher-ups at wherever
you work have said man you're the future
of this place and we're gonna invest in
you
and there's a part of you that's like
yeah that's what's up and there's
another part of you
that's like oh no they're going to find
out
is that fair you know yes that is
pretty accurate and you can
you how many kids you have i have two
you can raise two humans
and just i'm gonna do this
you know if
the thought of raising two kids by
myself that makes me want to not be
alive
and you just handle that with grace and
dignity and power and strength
getting on a stage is simple man that's
just acting you can be a clown
up there right so when you think of
getting on a stage have you ever just
gotten up
to give a speech and just blown it
just completely wet the bed on it
not that awful though i think i've
stumbled and you know
said a couple things that you know of
course i would have done differently but
no not
never got off stage and your co-workers
are like that's the last time you're
ever gonna do that
no i have i have
and i do this for a living right
are you still there sorry yes i lost you
for a second was that last question i
thought you said i'm out of here
i said no no no i'm saying i was
asking have you ever screwed up so bad
that your co-workers said hey you can
never speak here again
no okay i have and i do speaking for a
living that's my job
okay all right so tell me what are you
terrified of like what do you think is
gonna gonna happen happen
i think it's just a failure the not
living up to
okay especially now right now i'm in
this now it's like oh my god now you
have to just maintain and keep going and
and i i'm an over preparer okay
i will i will you know prepare
and and read over and look at everything
and try to prepare for all the questions
and
i think my biggest fear is that there's
a question that i don't have the answer
to
i'm going to teach you a magic magic
phrase you ready
while you're talking about being an over
preparer i'm watching james and kelly
they're just rolling their eyes back
there they're like wow that must be nice
to work with someone who actually
prepares
here's a magic phrase okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna save you a million dollars
ready repeat after me
i don't know i'm gonna find that out
i don't know i'm gonna find that out see
look at that
dude we were solving problems on this
show all right so here's the thing about
glossophobia that's just the nerd term
for fear of speaking in public right
it is uh i've never read the direct
study but anecdotally
it's repeated often enough that i'm
going to consider a fact for the time
being
that it is the most common phobia people
are
more scared of speaking in public than
they are of actually being
dead okay and for somebody who speaks in
public for a living
i can't wrap my head around that but i
do i can't
hear it enough to know here folks like
you that are like i would never
ever get on that stage and and do that
so does preparing wear you out or is it
exciting
is it fun um
i like i like getting you know when i
start feeling comfortable like okay i
got this like you know i'm here i got
that i got that but
yes i do get worn out sometimes okay so
a couple of things i want you to know
number one
i was working here and you know the name
dave ramsey is that name ring a bell
yes okay it was like three o'clock or
four o'clock in the afternoon
i just finished filming some stuff and i
was about to leave and there was a small
event this is right before cove kicked
off there's a small event
that was going to take place on a
saturday up here at the building that
they were filming for a video shoot
and wouldn't you know it that on stage
at three or four in the afternoon
was not only dave ramsey but also my
buddy chris hogan
who both of them have spoke like done
live events in front of
millions of people and there was a small
stage they were both on it they were
both
facing opposite directions and they were
practicing
a talk they were going to give to a
couple hundred people and that's when i
realized
oh that's what the greats do they
practice
they prepare and i had just been a guy
that would write down a speech on the
back of an envelope as i'm walking up on
stage
and it's gotten me by but i realized
whoa this is a whole other level of
preparation
and so you've already got that right
you've already got the part
where i need to make sure i know what
i'm going to say the people in the
audience
i want to be a steward of the most
precious resource on earth they have and
that's their time
but 30 minutes an hour that you're
giving that talk they can never have
that time back i'm gonna be a steward
i'm gonna practice i'm gonna know what
i'm gonna say
and so then from there i'm gonna give
you a couple things that can help you on
stage okay
and then a couple things off of it all
right so
i'm ready think of public speaking
not as a lecture but as a conversation
once when i switched from thinking i had
to
give info to us just having a
conversation with folks
everything my heart rate changed my
shoulders changed all my physiology
changed because
what i was doing in my body was
different i wasn't
talking at people i wasn't teaching at
people i was just talking to folks
and it just shifted and suddenly i've
given the same talk
to 10 people around a table that i've
given to a thousand people in auditorium
it becomes the same thing because i'm
having a conversation i can adjust it by
people and size
but it changes my whole heart right and
the speakers i've met that i love the
most
on stage are very similar to who they
are
off stage so instead of thinking it as a
performance as a make or break is now
i'm you know i'm a backstreet boy or i'm
jay-z like i gotta go up and like the
lights are on
i'm just having a conversation backstage
i was having a conversation with three
people
i'm gonna go have a conversation with
300 people on stage
it just shifts the entire your entire
physiology right
and then as things get more magnified
and bigger your heart state will
your heart rate will stay the same you
know you're going to talk about you're
prepared
right you're way ahead of me alicia and
then just becomes about
and i bet are you real funny my guess is
you
are real funny like dry witty
someone's going to say something and you
will just do mic drop after mic dropped
with your friend group is that fair
i can yes i can be very quick see if
there's something that
is completely non-work related i'm i'm
it's totally different that i'm like i'm
game let's do this but when it's work
related it's like
oh my gosh okay okay so here's here's
where that anxiety gap is
is the gap between you who's the person
that your company hired
you who is hilarious and your friends
love
and you're trying to put a space between
them and i want you to close that space
and i want you to be you
everywhere because the world needs to
hear about single moms who are awesome
and get put on leadership tracks
right right you've got some you've got
some wisdom to share
that me in my community here that your
work community needs to hear that the
world needs to hear right
is that fair yeah your company is paying
to
make you better they are fast tracking
you how can we get her in front of more
people
quicker that's how much they invest how
much they think you're good right
so i want you to close that gap and i
want you to be witty
and funny in conversation with your
buddies at the bar the
same way you got two kids you're not at
the bar the same way like at
wherever at daycare whatever i don't
know where you happen to be going from
place to place
um and i want you to be that same person
on a stage and they are going to eat you
up and that just
has to do with i'm going to have
conversation i'm not performing right
here's the second thing
the the nerd word is exposure therapy
that's just a fancy way for saying
you got to put yourself in situations
where you got to do it
and that can look like signing up for
different kinds of speeches
all different kinds of places if there's
a
a moms group a education group on
saturdays if it's a church group
whatever that looks like wherever you
can
get in front of folks to practice this
skill
of just being who you are off stage walk
up on stage heart rate never changes i'm
just gonna have a conversation
man you're gonna get better and better
and better at it because when you talk
to 10 you can talk to a thousand
if you can talk to a thousand or you can
talk to 100 you can talk to 5000. it's
easier that way because man they are
more distant and further along right
and then here's the final thing find
your humor in everyday moments and take
it on stage with you
give me a funny joke right now you can
do it do it make me laugh alicia
oh my god what's the funniest thing your
kid has done recently
oh my kid's in his 20s so they just
can't you know my kids are under 20 so
they make fun of me all
constantly so oh there's their 20s come
on man you are at the bar
all right so what's one thing that make
you laugh
what's one thing they do that makes me
laugh yes
oh when they just do imitations of of
how i raise them
okay so here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna take those imitations of
how they raise you and you're gonna
imitate them
imitating you and that's going to be an
awesome lead into your
to any sort of um talk you're going to
give and everyone in the audience is
going to
either have had parents that they
imitate and mock or they're going to
have kids
that they're tired of imitating them
right it's the whole you're man you're
going to build rapport with that with
that audience
find places to practice be who you're
going to be off stage on stage
just have a conversation with folks and
more importantly know this your company
would not be investing in you
if they didn't think you were the right
person here i want you to hang on the
line alicia i'm going to give you a copy
of
this book redefining anxiety this any
sort of phobia
tends to manifest itself when these in
this
this anxiety especially this this
situational anxiety
i want you to check this book out read
it um everybody else out there books 10
bucks it's
easy read if you can't read this book's
for you if you're really smart fancy
pants
it's for sure for you because you're not
that just kidding but yeah check it out
it's 10 bucks you can get it on
johndaloney.com
but alicia hang on the line and we're
going to mail you a free copy here
all right so as we wrap up today's show
i realized to all my metal buddies i'm
committing a party foul
and i don't care i don't care
in 2005 i listened all the way through
the record
and i was about to like cool it was a
good that was a good record man they did
a good job
then the last song the last i think it's
track 15
2005 off the record entitled xy
and i know you shouldn't do coldplay
songs but i'm doing it anyway
i'm doing it anyway
here's how the song goes right
steal my heart and hold my tongue i feel
my time my time has come
let me in unlock the door i've never
felt this way before
and the wheels just keep on turning the
drummer begins to drum
i don't know which way i'm going i don't
know which way i've come
hold my head inside your hands i need
someone who understands
i need someone someone who hears for you
i've waited all these years
for you i'd wait until kingdom come oh
man
i'm getting romantic now how do you not
love coldplay until my day
my day's done and say you'll come and
set me free just say you wait
you'll wait for me the name of that song
is till kingdom come i don't want to
give it away because you suckers have
bad attitudes about coldplay
especially you kelly this has been the
dr john dolone's show
[Music]
you